and again we go with 14 part of the
opening challenge getting out of my
normal opening routine French Tara yeah
I managed one poncy ani I'm supposed to
win two games in the pantheon E and yeah
I only got this one's over a couple of
games now in this bunch of uploads and
this in this week so seems to be
difficult they're difficult to get Joe
Bishop t6 that deadline is fairly ok for
black one of the best lines against the
French to rush i'm hoping i hope i'm
doing a good job in conveying the
perception that i'm actually knowing
something here I don't I actually don't
but those moves look fairly ok I mean
I'm got a healthy development and as it
is quite often with one year for
position some if you play fairly normal
or let's say active normal development
moves developing moves um very often
simply have an okay position I mean
there's nothing nothing fancy often okay
so what is this night f5 he's doing if
or I guess right age six check
oh I cannot go to a five for the shame
that's the real Jam not at five before
there's no way to make that work hmm at
age six checking edge and
what a shame so Bishop g5 he's going
Bishop c6 or what maybe maybe like to
get five a black must be okay he's
nicely centralized and it's a good
development I of course I wanted to go
to f5 him but it didn't work yeah yeah
he fought even even there okay it's the
only way to go not looking too great
their rookie five as an idea but that's
not c4 so he cannot go rookie fire that
easily so how am I going to get pieces
out shortly to kind of a lame move but
maybe we should be to 3-1 now yeah
that's all passive because of my time
loss then the opening with Knight d4 c 2
e 3 and so on if you cannot go to the
let's say normal square them on um f5
it's it's costly however how does he
make headway maybe Quincy 5e five has an
idea getting the Queen down on the
kingside my king side is that is the
issue nice night c4 is a bad idea
getting into the pin
that actually looks okay and help
yeah maybe I can try trading this bishop
and then night only three would be okay
yep let's do this to get rid of this pin
Joe I'm okay I'm totally okay now really
think that I'm okay night only three
years active and I have Quincy for maybe
this is this pawn on e4 is just blocking
his bishop so he's not having that great
of a position down
bit annoying if so if he goes to e7 I
have 95 possibly night f5 let's do this
Quincy 7mm any way to like 96 that's not
it's not really doing much fancy move
but not doing much maybe rickety phone
trying to double
wait maybe Queen tags actually it's an
interesting move but unconventional for
Queenie 3g5 maybe it's just rubbish but
interesting I can I can check on h6 this
also an idea oh really buttcheek 96 is
going back on 96 immediately is bad okay
so 96 on back back as I think actually
better controlling d5 you cannot put 95
rook Tijuana is some Rodney Bishop g5
Bishop b5 lucrative one I it's still not
a great weight the reason why I'm trying
to put something on d5 is that book do
you want otherwise occupies the D file
which is kind of okay but i'm probably
not really not having an advantage them
nice ok yeah he's okay him how do i can
i somehow get those pawns in motion
maybe this rookie form bishop yeah this
is a good idea let's get this in well
now that's not a good idea actually yes
confession 57 and I'm not threatening g5
I have led that took her claim that
wasn't good not a good idea
yeah maybe this one not a not a great
great idea this kind of thing come on
cheeks or bishops is sex is this
actually better Bishop c6 time warning
can do that first it doesn't have a
decent night move I think certainly rock
t seven so night f5 or sometimes that
not what's not working
and some check very Jewish imposition of
course Jeff
okay oh oh oh oh i forgot that yes that
came unfortunately not a big deal I
still still kind of embarrassing that I
forgot about the game grin okay yeah
that wasn't up-and-down thing opening he
had very nice position but I could I got
a good position later because the the
trades that we got in were quite
favorable for me so I think this is this
is getting getting to be nice so what
does the engine okay is this a Quincy
five that's nice actually a looking at
the dark squares he had 96 as a
possibility well it's probably better
here take sticks Jeff that's about equal
yeah I don't think with hindsight the
g-force leading to much it's probably
just a draw she surprised that he that
he went for Jack trade but this really
just said oh I already forgot that he
has f6 but it's still a draw with the
outside passim you can never be be worse
everything is traded yeah it looks that
looked like a fairly correct draw there
was never a situation where one of us
could could have one directly or gained
a very substantial advantage okay well
thanks for watching